welcome back don't start your weekend
yet
while china's space program is catching
up to hours believe it or not taking a
significant stride
this week launching astronauts to its
space station in fact it happened today
nasa has its greatest challenge to its
space supremacy
in 50 years are they responding well
let's listen
at nasa we're on a mission of equity
launching opportunity
equal opportunity to challenge and
inspire
to learn and thrive to reach those we've
never reached before
to use science data and technology
to advance equity
so not even space is safe from wokeness
it has infiltrated almost every facet of
the government
leading to explosive exchanges in
washington like this between congressman
jim banks
and navy admiral michael gilday watch
do you personally consider advocating
for the destruction of american
capitalism
to be extremist here's what i know
congressman so yesterday racism in the
united states navy
admiral you recommended every sailor in
the united states navy read this book
it's a yes or no question i'm not
forcing anybody to read the book the
book that you've recommended every
sailor in the united states
cherry picked quotes from somebody's
book
i'm not going to do that this is a
bigger issue than kendy's book
what this is really about is trying to
paint the united states military in this
case
the united states navy is weak as woke
well if the shoe fits uh put it on uh
joining us now michael walsh former
green beret and member of the space
committee congressman i'm horrified by
what i'm seeing
should i be yeah look i mean okay
more more diversity in in space in our
astronauts great what we need to be
focused on
is getting more americans into space
because right now
the chinese are passing us they are
kicking our butts
uh up there and it's it's a real problem
brian more launches more chinese
launches in space
last year than the rest of the world
combined including the united states
as you said just put their own
astronauts in their own space station
which is
brand new and being built ours is 30
years old
and decrepit china and russia have an
agreement to put a manned space station
on the moon by the end of the decade
they just uh the chinese just sent a
lunar lander and collected moon rocks
because they plan to mine the moon for
rare earth minerals
we haven't done that since uh the 1970s
and oh by the way they're on mars too
and what is the biden administration's
response
they just cut the program that would get
us to the moon by 2024
by 75 percent vice president harris
announced that she was going to continue
the national space council she has yet
to schedule a meeting i
you know maybe she'll get to that after
she gets to the border and after she
gets to europe
i don't know but meanwhile they're busy
making these videos
and worried about what color our
astronauts are i just want them to be
american and have that
american flag and not a chinese flag
because our entire modern economy
is dependent on what's up there and
militarily
you can't be number one on earth if
you're number two in space
lastly another area of expertise you
actually fight wars
and you're concerned like i am about
afghanistan for the last 20 years people
have helped us
out and those people their lives are in
jeopardy right now
those aids to americans what's happening
to them and how concerned are you
about the way we're pulling out brian
they're reaching out to me
uh and they are desperate and they're in
a panic right now they're being hunted
down by the taliban
not just them that stood and fought with
us but their families too
as they slowly take over the country in
the wake of our withdrawal
we can't abandon our allies the pentagon
is ready to get them out
and they are waiting on the word from
the white house
he didn't back the evacuation from uh
south vietnam and he's due and biden's
doing nothing about it now
it's shameful and by the way we have no
bases in the region if we have to go
back in after al qaeda
and it's not going to be like iraq where
we were there we just had to go back
we have to fight our way back and guys
like who are we going to go back to when
they're all
when they're all decimated yeah
congressman michael waltz thanks so much
appreciate it
all right thanks brian